nicht dass sie den leser oder anfangen
die wollen mich sehen darin die für
keiner sehen
es kann voll komisch weil dieser hinter
der kamera steht ist hallo mein name ist
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video von mir wie nahezu immer
sitze ich ja auch diesmal alleine bis
man dem titel eingeblendet ist meine
mutter verrät wie toll meine kleidung
ist die befindet sich allerdings gerade
hinter der kamera
gut das ganze video jetzt wird so
ablaufen
meine mutter möchte nicht gesehen wenn
ich möchte meine mutter nicht zeigen
dies sagt blabla auf jeden fall werde es
so ablaufen dass ich hier sitze und ich
beispielsweise ich hier ein
kleidungsstück zeige und meine mutter
kann ihre hand an
hier nehmen genauso mit der hand genau
so dann fühlt und dann sagen wie was sie
denkt wie wie teuer dieses produkt das
möchte ich übrigens nicht mit
irgendwelchen kleidungsstücken angeben
oder so aber ich würde einfach mal gerne
wissen wie nah du gerade an der jugend
klamotten bums dran ist also das erste
was ich hab die preise hier nicht dass
du die noch sich ist das erste was ich
hier vorbereitet habe ist eine kappe von
palace wie willst du diese kappe
bewerten und dafür die marke sagt mir
jetzt nicht gut aus
golfschlägern und als sich wichtig an
sich wichtig an durchlüftung die hitze
vom kopf nach oben gucken ob es nur eine
version kann ja handwäsche kann man
vielleicht auch im wahlprogramm oder
baumwolle atmungsaktiv 23 eur 23 euro
kostet 60 euro aber man muss also wäre
es glaube ich keinen preis komplett auf
den euro genau raten aber man muss auch
sagen dass pellets anhalt eine marke ist
die sowie supreme hattest du auch nicht
bekommen die launischen so immer so
wöchentlich oder alle zwei wochen
verschiedene produkte und dann halt nur
limitiert also die kann man jetzt auch
nicht mehr kaufen zudem kommt das aus
england die marke also darüber kommen
noch versandkosten dazu aber 60 euro was
nicht so weit entfernt das nächste
produkt was hier vorbereitet habe ist
underwear also eine boxershorts von
tiger tiger ich weiß nicht genau wie die
marke ausgesprochen wird kann es auch
mal fühlen frisch gewaschen sogar frisch
gewaschen wie viel grad was steht da wie
viel grad
wir haben also deutsche urlauber auf
jeden fall das kann man mit 30 oder 40
das bin ich ja beruhigt dass du es auch
nicht 30 finde ich schon mal nicht so
gut weil ich finde unterwäsche sollte
man 40 grad waschen können aber ich war
immer nur 30 grad
da nichts kaputtgehen kann aber qualität
ist gut ist es ein bisschen elasthan
drin ist baumwolle drin mischung und
kann man den trockner schmeißen habe ich
würde sagen 14 99 14 99 sie kostet 19
euro 99 aber immer sehr nah dran kommen
wir nun zum nächsten da habe ich hier
ein t shirt vorbereitet von of light
heißt die marke also so wie das von
vorne aus von hinten so mit den
diagonalen
feilen hier diagonale weiß nicht ob das
galaxy brass oder so war das halt
überall diese branche hat ist aus der
neuen kollektion glaube ich dass die
neues auch tatsächlich frisch gewaschen
von mir in köln riecht man auch sieht
total cool aus also gefällt mir knopf
teil super ihm einmal kittel war mir
schon klar würde ich auf links 10 auf
links sehen sich auf links gezogen
wenn du jetzt nicht grad 1600 1200 eine
produktion von zig tausend gibt einen
tipp sing sing swing
also ich würde sagen 79 90 79 90 sagst
du hast du auch zu denen die das hier
vorne also keine binder-farr 255 das ist
es ist aber auch limitiert also muss man
auch wieder sagen das ist halt wieder so
dass sich das kriegt man fast fast
nirgendwo mehr also das war schon
schwierig das überhaupt zu bekommen
kommen wir nun zu einem langarmshirt von
von disney bzw von aces hat mir
zugesendet micky maus steht da hinten
drauf musste jetzt auch sagen also kann
es natürlich wieder reinschauen was du
denkst wie teuer das ist ich habe die
preise hier stehen man muss sagen auch
eine marke die im high grade ist wo auch
eigentlich immer oder ja ja die marke
von 30 grad wäsche nicht in trockener
dass es aber fühlt sich super an
von mir gewaschen doch die qualität der
baum wurde scheint sehr gut zu sein
ja es wahrscheinlich immer angenehm zu
tragen ich würde sagen 69 90 25 euro
die erste mal dass über den preis liegt
ja es macht richtig gute sachen übrigens
viele leute fragen sich ja schon wann
das buch raus kommt ihr seht jetzt oben
grade wärmer wieder eingeleitet muss man
ja deutschen war kennzeichnen das buch
können wir ins final sagen haben von
drei minuten die mail bekommen am 14.12
kommt das buch raus was meine mutter und
ich geschrieben haben über mich also hey
freust du dich schon und wie das ok dann
die nächste sache die ich hier
vorbereitet habe ist ein wunderschönes
in steinen gewaschenes download t shirt
luxus steht hier drauf und neon orange
print was denkst du wie teuer ist das
ist auf 1000 euro ist nach richtig ja
kann man hier mit dem smiley sogar drin
extra gagen weil ich denke die dicken
ich weiß gar nicht virtuell deine
klamotten sind haben ja auch neues label
unten dran kann man 30 40 schon ein paar
tausend grad waschen es ist dass das war
doch die musste diese noch gar nicht
raus die kommen erst
der druck sie total jedes stück ist ein
unikat also jedes schön sieht anders aus
weil christian steinbach deswegen wieder
so krass ist sowas echt braucht sie doch
statt liebsten dafür dafür 4000 euro 34
90 ich glaube 31 eur 90 tja so günstig
wie viele werden jetzt wahrscheinlich
denken voll teuer für ein t shirt eine
freude das ist halt stone washed und
alles möglich und gerade diese branchen
kostet halt das halt nicht gerade jedes
jede hat anders von den von der waschung
her dann als nächstes würde ich sagen
nehmen wir diese schuhe hier da glaube
ich sogar dass es damals mitbekommen
dass es fünf stradivari zu bekommen also
du kannst du einfach mal fühle ich kann
mich aber auch machen wir das so nicht
sehen
adidas schuhe ich habe jetzt den retail
price genommen hat alle die sich jetzt
fragen sind wir in europa die sind diese
von adidas sind die ja gab es ist nicht
in jedem schule an design von kanye west
also von einem amerikanischen musiker
sind sehr bequem das ist sieht man schon
jemand bull ist weiß auch nicht sind
auch zu bruch muss seine einlagen
passender wahrscheinlich auch mein
lassen daher kann es dann raus nehmen
irgendwann kann die rausnimmt ich würde
jetzt so sagen die wachstum wie teuer
sind diese schuhe gerade wie teuer sind
total 130 130000 167 euro kosten diese
schuhe doch besser die damals design mit
adidas hatte die rausgebracht und noch
zwei andere modelle das war in einer
turtle dorfhalle bleibt und das ist
glaube ich oxford ein und die haben
ursprünglich irgendwie zwischen 200 und
300 gekostet so normal dass nick price
von vernünftigen sneaker nur dadurch
dass die limitiert waren sind die im
preis total gestiegen da habe ich hier
noch einen pulli vorbereitet wieder
kannst du dir auch einfach mal
was ich sage ist eine kamera hier das
ist der pulli hatte ich auch ein paar
instagram bildern mal an hier so von
vorn von der seite obersten hier kannst
du auch mal anfassen da ist da fehlt was
für eine qualität direkt was abgegangen
oder war ja wie gesagt so auf haut
direkt trägt man ja nicht mal einen
unterhändler t-shirt unter 30 grad
wäsche gucke ich wieder und das gewebe
sieht ganz gut aus der faden lauf ist
gerade also dann verzieht sich auch
nichts es bleibt so von der qualität da
wird sich nichts irgendwie abnutzen
schützen
80 99 euro cook sowie zu ab 199 du musst
bedenken es ist die gleiche marke von
denen das t shirt ja auch wandelt das
ist deswegen hatte ich das 199 ist kommt
er kostet 415 euro ist halt auch wieder
dieses ohne das ding limitiert ohne dass
dinge 400 ja genau muss ich mir das aha
du klar das ist nicht cool
da hat man heute schon getötet wir waren
beim aber man hat mich so ins geheime
gefahren wie teilzeit in die jacke
eigentlich nicht mal hörte video also
kannst du einfach mal fühlen dann kommt
schon teilweise raus also die beim
hersteller das war nicht so gut
verarbeitet handynummer steht hier schon
geschwitzt danach waschen dann im
trockner und dann mit tennisbällen
natürlich damit sie wieder schön fluffig
wählt die macht vom bakom crafter 600
euro 450
na ja krass das waren somit das zweite
mal dass du darüber geschätzt hast
kommen wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
letzten und zwar ist es dass ich hier
gerade an habe das ist aus der früheren
kollektionen von justin bieber also hier
vorne stehen
ich denke die ganzen ich habe nach dem
dreh schwer wenn papa geklaut hier kind
drauf hier vorne lieber also du kannst
einfach mal fühlen an dem stoff oder
falls irgend was also kann man 40 grad
waschen muss halt überlegen justin
bieber das gemacht und das war halt
direkt auch wieder ausverkauft und alles
mögliche ist ja klar ich glaube deshalb
seinen wert die sind natürlich gibt es
heute nicht mehr machen dann kann man es
nicht erklärte dass über h&m gemacht
eigentlich aber die werden also die gibt
es nicht mehr
also was ist heute für einen wert hat
oder für ein paar cent als musiker sagen
wir wie ich für den preis für denise
gekauft habe 49 euro es hat sechs euro
99 gekostet tatsächlich
bei helmut m also das ist ja doch sechs
euro 99 ich habe 6 eur 990 bezahlten t
shirt lang haben die städte 69 60 das
kann eigentlich nichts vernünftiges sein
das hat jetzt ihr vom video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen es getan hat las gern mal ein
like da wie gesagt ich möchte dir
überhaupt nicht mit irgendwas angeben
oder so ich glaube kennt mich da relativ
gut aber ich fand es ganz cool mal
herausfinden was meine mutter denkt wie
tolle klamotten von mir sind habe ich
das ein bisschen orientiert an die video
von merkels ronning das findet in der
beschreibung und verlinkt das ist ein
englischer fashion blogger hätte das mit
seinem vater zusammen gemacht dass wir
auch sehr unterhaltsamen jetzt natürlich
noch viel krassere sachen irgendwie
valencia gas und vom supreme noch viel
mehr mit dabei ansonsten will ich das
video der stelle jetzt auch beenden wie
gesagt kommt das buch am 14.12 uhr raus
mein neues menschen da ist wo ich euch
unter anderem ja schon dieses t shirt
hier gezeigt habe kommt am ersten 12 und
jetzt kommt das auto